That's a burbot.
Holy.
Look, Maya.
I got it?
Yeah, you got it.
Maya was able to pull out a
lush, which was a big deal.
Because it's a
different kind of fish.
None of my kids ever seen one.
I've never caught one.
And I was really proud
of her to be able to pull
in a nice lush like that.
Feels good to get a burbot.
My first time ever catching
one, first time with the kids.
They're excited.
I'm excited.
Did she see little
Maya pull it out?
That's golden.
I can't believe
we got a burbot.
That's so cool.
We still have more
lines to check, too.
Oh, yeah.
Well, there's a fish on it.
Holy.
That's a big pike.
That's a huge pike.
Dang.
Ooh.
Oh, that's a big pike.
It's dead.
Huge.
Eee.
I have a good
lever inside of it.
Let me show you the other one.
Pull it in, then.
You got another one?
Yep.
Oh, it's still alive.
Burbot.
Come on, burbot.
[inaudible]
It's a burbot.
Burbot.
Man, it's a huge one.
Look at it.
Oh.
That's a big one.
Huge, huh?
Yeah, and now we can eat--
OK, so we got--
--two ones.
Oh, oh, oh.
It's like a big snake.
Gee.
Stand right here.
Let's see how big
it is next to you.
Its tail is on the ground.
[laughs]
It's big is you, Maimai.
Uh.
OK, we're going to
make a little fire
and cook some
burbot, have a feast.
It's definitely a
different-looking fish.
See how like, the
flakes are bigger.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, look at those moose.
A baby [inaudible].
Yeah, a baby moose.
Oh, oh.
Hey, it listened to her.
It listened to you.
Oh.
Holy, Maya, you're going to
be hunting moose pretty soon.
That's the beauty of having
kids, and being in the woods,
and being happy out here.
It's just part of being with
nature and part of being
with your culture is learning
to enjoy yourselves while you're
getting food on the table.
My hands are so tired,
they're shaking.
[inaudible]
More.
Mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm.
It's good.
You have another one, Mai?
Yeah.
Jeez, that fish is gone quick.
That was so [inaudible].
It was?
No more.
That was good, huh?
Mm-hmm.
I just want to fall
back and go to sleep.
Me too.
[inaudible]
Good.
Good job, Maya.
Good job fishing.
[inaudible]
All right, there.
[music playing]